this right here is Apple's new $1300
bass 13-inch MacBook Pro that finally
comes with the new quad-core processor
and we're going to connect it to the
same a GPU that we previously connected
to the top-spec 15-inch MacBook Pro
where we concluded that adding in Egypt
you wasn't worth it but as you'll see in
this video we're completely changing our
mind because this $2,000 setup works
like a dream so for the GPU system we're
using the $300 razor core X with a $400
radeon vega 64 graphics card and
combined with the new $1,300 base 13
inch macbook pro that makes for a total
of two thousand dollars for this setup
compared to three thousand five hundred
and forty nine dollars with the top spec
15-inch 2019 macbook pro now of course
the 15-inch model is gonna have its high
performance wherever it goes
while the 13-inch needs to be connected
to an e GPU to get the performance we're
about to show you in this video but a
lot of people actually prefer the
portability of the 13-inch for when
they're on the go so this setup actually
makes a lot of sense even without any
GPU the new $1300 13 inch base macbook
pro actually performs very well and
we'll be comparing it directly to the
$1,800 13-inch pro very soon so if
you're not already subscribed do so now
and without further ado let's get into
performance and Geekbench force graphics
test we can see that we now get a lot
more graphics performance than the
15-inch MacBook Pro now that we're using
the each of you and in Unigine heaven a
gaming benchmark we're now getting
almost double the gaming performance
compared to the 15-inch model with Vega
20 graphics so if you're wanting to game
on your macbook pro this is the perfect
one to use with an e GPU now let's move
on to some video editing tests and Final
Cut Pro which do a great job of
utilizing both graphics and processor
performance let's start with the Bruce X
benchmark which almost purely uses
graphics and as you can see the each of
you set up is actually finishing faster
than the $3,500 MacBook Pro and now onto
video stabilization of 4k footage it's
also finishing slightly faster than the
15-inch pro once again and it's actually
five times faster than the integrated
graphics alone so these tests were
mainly using graphics performance which
we know is a lot faster on the
GPU but now let's do some tasks that
also use up a good amount of processing
performance as well at first like to
mention that the top spec 15-inch
MacBook Pro gets an 8 core eye 9 CPU
which is obviously much much faster than
the 1.4 gigahertz quad-core in the
$1,300 base model but let's give it a
chance
starting with editing common 4k footage
with a couple of effects and let's added
to it this is basically what most
youtubers are going to be editing if
they're shooting in 4k and we see here
that the base MacBook Pro with the e GPU
is actually not too far off from the
15-inch so this is really impressive for
paying only 2000 dollars compared to
$3,500 and interestingly when we
previously added the GPU to that same
15-inch pro it actually took longer for
some reason around the same time as a
13-inch pro with the e GPU so we're
getting a lot more out of it now let's
move on to some heavy duty footage c200
4k raw at 60 frames per second
we actually got a massive improvement
with the e GPU connected exporting
around three times as fast and not too
far behind the 15-inch MacBook Pro and
not only that but when we playback the
timeline the each APU triples the amount
of FPS we get while editing almost as
much as the high-end model alone so it
actually becomes bearable to edit this
footage and now exporting 4.5 K red raw
footage that's extremely processor heavy
we're actually seeing another massive
improvement with the e GPU we're still
not quite at the 15-inch Perlas level
but it beats waiting over 40 minutes to
export this clip these are only a few
limited video editing tests but we're
extremely surprised that we're getting
this much performance out of the base
$1300 MacBook Pro with a $700 GPU and
the biggest difference was in tasks that
mainly used the graphics like gaming and
graphics rendering so if you're doing
work that's heavily dependent on
graphics performance then this $2,000
system is for you but the most
impressive thing was how we also saw a
major difference in processor heavy
tasks as well and the reason for that is
because the quad-core processor was
being held back by the limited
performance of the integrated graphics
in the EGP you gave the processor all
the room it needed to perform at its
best in need I remind you that this
MacBook only has 8 gigabytes of RAM
is performing this well so if you're
gonna upgrade anything on this MacBook
Pro upgrade the RAM first absolutely
don't pay $300 for the i7 upgrade it's
not gonna do much at all so what only
$1,300 I'm officially crowning the 2019
13-inch base MacBook Pro the best
MacBook you can get if you're gonna use
an e GPU and also as the overall best
value MacBook out of any macbook we've
seen in years we've also tested a lot of
a GPU systems and this razor core X
enclosure combined with the Radeon Vegas
64 is the best bang for the buck each of
you system we've seen and we also have
AMD's brand new Radeon 5700 XT in the
office but we won't be able to test it
until we get driver support hopefully in
Mac OS Catalina this fall and if you're
wondering how this $1300 MacBook Pro
compares to the $1,800 2.4 gigahertz
model that video is coming very soon so
if you're not already subscribed click
the circle above so you don't miss out
on that video tap like and make sure to
check out one of those two videos right
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one
[Music]